well um there he is remember him
remember him who's not gonna have a job
on snl anymore because trump's not the
president
oh yeah no they're gonna stop making fun
of trump now mm-hmm
you think uh going nowhere
so let's do this let's read the story
first
it's from the irish times your people
hilaria baldwin
the strange story of alec baldwin's wife
and her fake spanish roots
let's do this um let's see let's uh
let's
pop her on the screen too it's only it's
it's
let's see i want to really here she is
baby there she is
um is that her is that the person
interviewing her there she is
uh the first signs that hilaria
baldwin's life was going seriously off
the rails came from the same place
where she usually derives her sense of
control
i started seeing comments on my
instagram she said in an interview
it's a very strange thing and you can
just be living your life
she said when suddenly comments begin to
mount suggesting that you
a famous person is she famous
is she famous just for [ __ ] alec
baldwin
i mean fame by proxy mackenzie bezos is
rich right
yeah a famous person who has shared so
much of yourself with
hundreds of thousands of followers and
not who they thought
followers are not who you thought not
who you thought you to be
and find you very your very identity the
subject of
international debate and skepticism over
the last week or so millions of people
uh cooped up and tired and probably two
online at the end of the year
have been surprised to learn that
hilaria baldwin 36
and the mother of five children with her
husband alec baldwin
is not a spaniard but an american
who was born and raised it's at least a
hispanic town
boston and who who was known
as until 2009 hillary baldwin
changed her name to hell it swear to god
no i swear to god
i was going to say because hilaria is
like a weird name yeah
um so
we have an opportunity to clarify for
for people who have been confused and
have been confused in some ways by
people misrepresenting me
now uh it's very surreal said baldwin
who said she had been called hilaria by
family members for almost all her life
there is not something i'm doing wrong
here and i think there's a difference
between hiding and creating a boundary
for days the internet and the news media
have dogged her
sharing evidence of baldwin speaking in
a spanish accent
in a video uh but none that one
but not that one or fluffy
magazine spread in hola which is spanish
for high
oh okay that makes sense that uh not to
be confused with aloha
which is hawaiian for high my favorite
was they had an
a spanish language newspaper growing up
on long island called
hoy they had a jewish one called oi
yeah they had a jew they had a couple
jewish ones right new york times
just newspaper okay you just insert
newspaper name here
hola that cites her as a native spanish
speaker of to
orr of a today show clip showing her
making gazpacho
and asking de la munto de la mundo's
eva cisco what the english word for
cucumber is
oh i am so sorry you do not like it
called the soup
she was asking telemundo's eva cisco
what the english word for cucumber is
she was born in boston her whole life
she lived in boston
uh and of the biography posted on the
website creative arts agency caa which
represents like
everybody in hollywood i love your
american food this is so delicious what
do you call this delicacy
that's cream of chicken soup
just got it out of a can to tell you how
did you say that in english
the talent agency her talent agency says
that she was born
in mala marukara spain
baldwin is bilingual and she speaks
english with a varying degree of spanish
accents depending on how happy or upset
she's feeling she said
she didn't know that ola magazine for
which she has twice posed for the cover
and
and which has written some 20 items
about her on its
english language website so far that she
repeatedly reported inaccurately that
she was
a spaniard because she said she didn't
read articles about herself
that's a lie uh first time appearing on
live television she was nervous
yeah the first time you sucked alex alec
baldwin's dick you put a google alerts
out on your name
she and she says she got so confused
about the word cucumber because it was
her first time appearing on live tv and
she was nervous she forgot the word
cucumber as for ca
bio she could only assume the agency
used unverified information from the
internet to write a sloppy bio the
information unverified information that
she has not corrected never corrected
anybody
but now look here's the cool thing being
from boston um which is a
again traditionally hispanic town
listen when i think of hispanic accents
i think of matt damon
ben affleck those are the people i think
norma garcia para
so if she's from boston why doesn't she
sound like kevin sullivan or
johnny boston or somebody well you know
the first time i
shocked alec baldwin's [ __ ] it was
pretty amazing
uh well here's the fun part uh alec
baldwin one time was on david letterman
and the quote is
my wife is from spain alec baldwin once
said on tv to david letterman
but all the misconceptions are why she
agreed to speak to a reporter for the 80
minutes
as she cuddled and nursed her infant son
bringing the sun bringing the sun by the
tip to kind of protect you to shield you
we have an opportunity to clarify for
people who have been confused and have
been confused in some ways
people misrepresenting me so i have some
clips here over the years
sure of alec baldwin and her uh
remember she said that she never claimed
she were from spain why would people get
that idea
i'm reading what those things are is
false
and some of it's so spectacularly false
and they've said it about people i love
falsehoods
you got to consider the source is he
studying the kevin spacey
school of making videos yes
consider the source consider the source
consider the source
consider the source really okay i can't
wait to see you that's going to be great
the fantastic what time 12 o'clock my
wife is from spain
and she said and blah blah blah i don't
mean to be racist when i put that accent
on there by the way
very nice no how do you say you say
ilaria elaria
do people call you hillary sometimes and
you know it's
that's her name so it's it's happy
family lives in spain okay
and i have moved to new york when i was
19 years old wow so you're noticing no
accident there right
she moved to new york when she was 19.
her family's from spain
she's implying that she moved to new
york from spain no mention of boston by
the way
can i just point out that her maiden
name is hillary
hayward thomas it's the waspiest
sounding boss i've ever heard in my life
your english is well speaking both
english and spanish
okay so um so yes so you hear that no
accent we're hearing no accent now right
that's how she talks children my parents
are spanish my
my ancestors are from spain they came
here on the boats
known
i am from spain this is much like
christopher columbus
so um so yes and my children my parents
are spanish
my um my family is mixed of a bunch of
different things
so they're white yeah
you do the flamenco you are very espanol
so my wife oh my god that was so cringe
that was so crazy
very cringe sir to pee every five
minutes i can't believe it
that was as close as he could get to
spain to my family
she's so white by the way and by the way
go back the amount of bronzer she
started putting on
since then like you go back and she's
like a cute white chick
you know you're like damn she yeah she
cute but she's white as [ __ ]
and now she's you notice she's tanning
more and she's
it's so dude this is [ __ ]
cr i'm embarrassed oh it gets worse that
was
as close as he could get to spain to my
family
35 or 40 of my family members come from
spain
we're going to go to espana to see my
family
oh espana you notice the accent how the
how the accent's starting to get used
you really feel
how she went from yeah you know i lived
in new york too
but espana even the way she said it
sounds so
white espana with my family i'm going to
bring him
he's never well we brought spain to him
for the wedding but now he's got to
purchase
that's physically impossible man i
wouldn't fit yeah you wouldn't be able
to bring a country
what boat and what boat
and look at your skin color look at look
at your skin
potatoes we have um
cucumbers cucumbers
oh i read it but seeing it is worth
seeing it is worth seeing it is way how
do you say it in english
i love it this dish is so good how did
you say
in english it's kraft macaroni and
cheese
it's on the box ma'am it's just craft
how do you say in english he says
captain crunch oh god
oh god oh god i'm just saying england
how'd you say in english
uh it's raisin bran it's just bran
and they throw some raisins how do you
say how do you say oh no
oh god i feel i ca i'm gonna try okay
i'm gonna try to play the rest of this
this is really bad here we go
cucumber cucumbers you know how
important it is for you that your kids
speak spanish and how is your spanish
coming along now this is a woman with an
actual spanish accent a speaker spanish
muy bien but i have to say to you it's
one of the
things that makes our relationship work
because he can be being him and i'm like
really angry with him
and then i can say something and he's
like what did you say and i'm like
noticing do you see you feeling the
accent now a little bit more
see that is the thing about our marriage
you know it's like okay so like you know
i am a complete batshit crazy woman who
changes her accent depending on her mood
and he is a diagnosable narcissist
who really doesn't care as long as i
give up my [ __ ]
and um the other thing that helps our
marriage work is we have money
so we have a very big house we don't
need to see what part of speedy from
um from um from uh
i'm trying i was trying to think of like
something southeast spain
from southeast asia i was trying to
think of what's that other town that
they always it's just outside of boston
i
couldn't think of it and i love you
it happened and then he says again and
he said something again and now he can
say something and i'm like i said you're
right all the time
so it's like i really get so it's like
so it's like i like so it's like in the
saudi time
what's up with this guy's shorts by the
way it was waltham
thank you thank you i am from waltham
spain
sorry zacco she's from somerville spain
i am from charleston spain dorchester
spain
i'm from a little villa in spain just
outside of barcelona it's called
framingham
oh framingham framingham is you gotta
roll your eye framingham
i heard they have good clam chowder
there it's pretty good
oh [ __ ] to like just like let the steam
off so i'm not like holding on to
tension sure her friends just speak
spanish they're all making fun of me
like what did you say she's like
i said that you're the sexiest man i've
ever heard this is not my first night
out
oh here it is okay see see how it see i
told you it gets worse and worse
yeah here you go look at this one this
is not my first night out
i got my butt out of bed it doesn't
matter when they put that baby on you
my wife was a professional dancer and
traveled around the world dancing with a
group of people you know uk china
where else did you go i went to a lot of
places
there is a lot of love there's a lot of
sparkles during the winter
because your wife's name is hilaria is
it hilarious
it's hilarious oh it's so stupid it's
actually very funny it's hillary okay
my wife ellaria really is this
this preposterously unique person she's
able to juggle she's the most
but she's the most healthy person
emotional what happened i'm sitting here
like
i'm in my room and something happens
yeah and my wife will come in and be
like you know
alec what good does this do for you i
love this i love the the
the coping with alex baldwin to her is
like no she's literally like
she's the healthiest person mentally
like i've never
the doctor said they've never met
anybody more mentally stable than my
wife that's great it's crazy how normal
a doctor said that yes
yeah doctors don't normally say that
they say whatever you want when you're
famous oh okay i didn't know that
i wasn't aware and she just said so
she's so [ __ ] reasonable right it's
exhausting
let's look at this okay i'm just saying
to you right now
and my wife woke up right you scare him
you're so intense and you say and my and
like i can't do anything
you know what else i know this has
nothing to do with the her accent and
being weird and all this [ __ ] but
i really want to highlight too this is
what i love about people like alec
baldwin he is the quintessential boomer
because all these guys that like
leave their families right like he has
remember his daughter that he called a
fat pig
oh yeah yeah so he has daughters
he had a wife he had a family but
he's too busy drunkenly calling his
older daughter and calling her a fat
[ __ ] pig in a slob
and and saying all this awful [ __ ] to
her on the phone but he's so
just completely in love with his new
family he's so enamored with them he's
so infatuated
with his new pretty wife and his new
little baby that's gonna grow up
and eventually stop being cute and he's
gonna be like yeah [ __ ] it
fat piece [ __ ] like you know what i mean
like these guys are so
in their own little [ __ ] world
they're sociopathic about it
always been a zara fan it's you know it
is a spanish brand and um so i've known
about it since for a very very very long
time before i was in this country
whoa i've known about this a very very
long time before i was in this country
but wasn't she from boston you see when
my family
immigrated here from brockton we had to
sneak into a country
to get here and it was very hard um
you know we came from a small
spanish village mostly known for farming
called bunker hill
or i'm sorry miss pronouncing bunker eel
thank you the h's the h is silent when
you're in
all ages are silent where i come from
how does it spell it like romeo well
then it's romeo yeah
why do you say i'm so glad i gave you
whenever i have a baby you clear these
things up for me it's great
i've been calling my son the wrong name
for the last eight months what's what's
your son saying romeo or romero
and i've been calling him you [ __ ]
stupid little is that normal
is that what you call your kid sometimes
i punch him for no reason i don't know
why
remember when he got in trouble for
getting to a fight over a parking lot
yes
a parking spot and he had to go anger
management for it you do that to him
well i just live in my family
i love in my family that i don't speak
the least spanish like carmen is fully
bilingual
in fact i think i might have said this
last night here she like leans into her
mother and she's like
daddy oh my speaks english
you know i'm like they really like ride
me so i say romeo
[Music]
when you love somebody you want to
defend them
when you love somebody you want to
defend them definitely lives in spain
they live in my york
no no no no no she's married to pablo
escobar she does yeah she looks like she
just got off the planet from medellin
no no no i moved here when i was 19 to
go to nyu ah
from my family by look at
did you see that i'm sorry i don't mean
to cut you off but you got to hear this
part again
i'm sure your parents no no no i moved
here when i was 19 to go to nyu
ah from my family lives in spain they
live in my york
from my family lives in spain
implying that she moved in from spain
when she moved here from boston
yeah it's she's full of [ __ ] but alec
baldwin's encouraging this crazy [ __ ]
too
um because part of the problem here that
i'm noticing is he's like fetishizing
this spicy latina thing you know like
he's
he he every interview clip that you've
showed so far is him like yeah she looks
like she just
got off the plane from medellin and oh
yeah
they're rolling the r's and she's
bilingual like he's upset
he's more obsessed with her fake latina
ancestry than she is yeah you're right
because he's fetishizing it because he's
like look at my spicy
wife no that's true it's also not
fashionable now to be a white dude right
like he is
no of course not so it's it's this
diversity by proxy diversity by proxy
where it's like
well my wife's hispanic or like robert
de niro does i have i've had
black wife like it's it's a way to to go
i'm not as white as or de blasio's
another great example de blasio is
another one that lives in this weird
delusional world
it's [ __ ] hilarious okay
so yeah that would make sense uh can
reveal that she grew up in a 100 year
old 4 million dollar house
in the heart of the most desirable
district in boxing beacon beacon hill
baby
she grew up if he can help this house of
beacon hill
dude her parents bought the five bed
five bath house in
1987 when their daughter was there just
three years old and didn't move out till
she turned
28. so not only is she just a regular
white girl 28 years old but she's a
she's a white girl who's literally done
nothing
wow you wouldn't know that pop culture
of
well i know i knew no i know no pop
culture i don't know anything about
white people
is what do you mean so she's pretending
like she's not from this country knows
no pop culture
she lived until she was 28 years old in
beacon [ __ ] hill
uh well i know i knew no i know no pop
culture anywhere now i'm better but i
knew
no pop culture my wife was born in the
united states
in boston and then from a very young age
her father's mother's family
the paternal grandmother is from spain
so only the paternal grandmother
is from spain i'm just gonna start
talking with an irish brogue everywhere
i go
oh top of the morning to you yeah i'm
from ireland
genial genealogist dr aiden newman
says there's no spain in sight after
tracing your lineage back to
england ireland germany quebec and
slovakia speaking of daily mail dr aiden
says
nothing led me nothing led me to spain
after fleshing out a
dirty tree going back centuries on
hilarious maternal side
the first haywards arrived from england
to connecticut
in the 1870s you were choking you're off
by a bit
but still joking so the 1870s [ __ ] is a
mayflower [ __ ]
i was kidding i was joking
and that side of her family her father's
family
and my wife came to spain and went to
school for many years she was educated
both places from a very young age back
in
what i don't get is she no no no no she
lived in boston
but what i don't why would you wanna
why why would you want to start a whole
family based on a lie like wouldn't
wouldn't you want
your kids to know they're like good or
bad by the way i'm not saying that
you know you may find out that you've
got some
um somebody in your bloodline that was
like an infamous
criminal or whatever the case is it may
not always be good news
but wouldn't you rather know the truth
like wouldn't you rather tell your
children
the truth about their origins wouldn't
you want your children to know
what their genetics are so that if they
ever are in some kind of a terrible
health
crisis that they can um
they can get the proper treatment and
that doctors would be able to identify
uh any genetic things that might be
causing you your health probably
wouldn't you want your child to be armed
with as much of
the truth as possible as they go into
their future
not build some kind of weird lie for
them like
it's just odd to me it's an odd impulse
to do well
but but it's i would agree with you but
not now think about the culture we're in
now
now having any sort of diversity in you
makes you cooler
so it really is just it's just being
cool
that's what it is now if you have
hispanic in you you're cool you're
you're a minority you're this you're
that you're right i would agree with you
that
what you're saying is the correct way
you should live but now you could
it's it's like it's like when brad and
[ __ ] angelina adopt [ __ ] mixed
babies from all over the planet
they're collecting them like pokemon
because they want to be as diverse as
possible
and fourth half the year in the year in
america half the year in spain i'm not
sure
that was she that was angelina mostly
though yeah you're right
i don't think brad pitt woke up on the
set of a movie and was like yo
baby let's go fly to africa and shop for
black babies
i don't think that was his impulse that
would be a cool way to say it though
he obviously feels that both places are
home
my wife is alive
and she grew up here for many years
is a lovely wonderful girl she's from
hey steven us mallorca and from boston
half of her family she's
she's been back and forth throughout her
her life you gotta consider the source
it's not hilaria it's not it's hilarious
even
hilaria there is no h there's no h it's
hillary
your name is hillary oh
god pretend there's no h it's
like hola in spanish you say hola it's
h-o-l-a
nobody says hola unless you have a
really bad accent no it's not
i wanna i wanna keep saying too it's not
hillary
because even to say that rice is is
understating it her name is
hilary lynn hayward thomas i need to get
from beacon hill okay hilary lynn
hayward thomas from beacon hill boston
speaking spanish
let's do it for us together look at this
act remember for the last video
now listen to this well listen to this
accent lay it on thing you want her to
speak in spanish for spanish together
here's what's happening you see what's
happening here he's putting her on the
spot saying no no do it in spanish and
she's panicking doesn't want to
no no no let's do something else no i
don't want to do it
for the love of god
i would be like i
if i'm embarrassed for somebody
especially if i'm dating somebody and
they're being embarrassing and they're
making me embarrassed by proxy
it would affect my ability to be
attracted to them like i would be less
hurt like
if i noticed that a girl i was dating
just kept kind of
phasing in and out of different accents
i'd go like
why like i i can't live like the guy i
don't know how people can just live
in these fantasy worlds and not get
frustrated and address the things that
they're noticing i would be like why do
you keep
why do you keep doing that like doing
what like
you're normal and then you're not normal
then you're hispanic and then you came
in you were speaking klingon the other
day like
what are you doing this is weird this is
not normal behavior
i speak dothraki it's like come on man
like
how does how is he not like [ __ ]
mortified
uh i say to my son
jesus were alive today he would be
following ellaria and on easter he'd be
doing yoga okay following
baldwin on instagram so cringe begging
for her to followers
yes long story short he kept looking at
me and my friend was like alec baldwin's
looking at you and i'm like
like i grew up with no tv i'm like okay
um and then we left and he grabbed my
hand
i think here's a clip of her speaking
spanish hold on hold on
but i'm trying to see if it's good
spanish let's see no [ __ ] i'm already
can tell she speaks spanish
like somebody who learned spanish second
yeah i'm trying
let's see this this is her speaking
spanish i want to hear maria
mariano
it's not great spam it's okay spanish
but it's but it's not spam
it's learned spanish it's not spanish
from somebody from spain because she's
stopping to think of words
yeah she is you're right she is stopping
to think of words
which i mean if you didn't speak spanish
as your native tongue and you were
speaking spanish that's really good
i'd be like god damn you speak some good
spanish but
i also wouldn't think that i'd be like
oh did you learn that in your native
land
of beacon
[Music]
look again it's she she speaks spanish
okay
doesn't really speak it like a native
person
but it's all right
it's all right i mean i still think the
most embarrassing thing about her is the
fact that she has to [ __ ] alec baldwin
yeah she does [ __ ] him on purpose huh
yeah that's pretty pretty [ __ ] bad